anyway what are we gonna talk about
today so uh obviously when I talk about
tooling I mean you probably got that
from the title we're gonna talk about
quality but more than quality when I
talk about enforcing quality keeping the
level of quality the same not basically
going worse but then I mean keeping as
good as you are it's only one part of
the problem right you also want to
probably raise it from wherever it is
because if the bar is really low
well you can keep it there but that's
probably not the objective you have
right you probably want to upgrade it to
and we will focus on automation because
again who programmers were lazy we like
to have somebody else do our job but
still get paid and also I mean this is
the first the first part is gonna be for
your manager because at some point
you're gonna have to make a case for it
because I mean that's the first thing
he's gonna ask like well that sounds
nice but how much it's gonna cost me so
this is basically what we're gonna talk
in the first part because I don't like I
mean I thought about this very hard when
I maybe said oh yeah obviously we're
gonna you want this because of quality
and then I remembered his talk I had
with the manager of mine a couple times
I don't know exactly a couple years ago
maybe and he was like oh you engineers
you just want quality for quality sake
that's an engineering thing like yeah
you know we're nerds with just one
quality for quality think there is like
this is the only reason we want it this
is not really true or so I hope there's
actual reasons why we want quality is
just not because we're being very
pedantic there's actual reasons and
that's that's why I try to think about
so what are the words that comes to mind
like okay let's you my audience that's
perfect you have totally not seen my my
my Twitter question before or maybe you
have if you follow me what comes to mind
if in quality I say like oh these code
bases quality what what do you expect
few bucks yeah that's that's a good one
actually I call it robustness it's yeah
it's Roberts you know what it's just
that it works it actually does what it's
supposed to do that's one able to be
changed
oh did you see the slides before or what
we have absolutely not coordinated
before just so you know okay you can get
a guess that there's at least two more
bullet points so what else he's gonna
come in
in your mind cute that's an interesting
one that's not the first one I would
fall about but what redouble almost I
put ease of use like yeah so basically
yes it's row bursts it's maintainable
it's easy to use and since your manager
is maybe in the room it's also cost you
know Chris I mean we were talking about
it yeah okay we get all that stuff but
how much is it gonna cost me
so let's talk about this thing so
robustness of course we mean but free
but not only we also think about other
stuff like possibility you don't have to
be a hundred percent portable with
platforms you will never ship for but
you have to be reasonably portable like
probably try to not abuse too much the
own my machine it works thing not rely
on undefined behavior and that kind of
stuff because I mean software changes
and maybe at some point you will have to
move to 64 bits like I did in three
different projects or you will have to
go on another operating system or you
will just get a new version of the
compiler and if it actually works
because you're relying on implementation
beefy the defined stuff you have some
issues you nice test coverage is also a
thing I mean I don't even know how you
guarantee row business without unique
test coverage you can probably manual
test but it has some limits an error in
like this is probably the one that was
suggesting the less or a die here the
less when people think about robust code
it's how well do you handle errors not
only like you actually handle them which
is like a first but the second one is
like you tell either the programmer or
the user which might be a programmer
what happened and what can you do what
can you do about it I make video games
right so we I think a lot about UX and I
think I know people hate when you're
good just get a public saying error that
doesn't help anybody so yeah I think our
end link is probably the one that is for
plus the for the less when we talk about
quality when we talk about
maintainability I usually goes
hand-in-hand I think with simplicity
right like the simplest code is the
easiest to maintain because it's like so
dumb you can't you can't it's foolproof
you can't you can't you can't become you
can't mess it
expressiveness Oh
so comes together like if you could is
expressive it's easier for people who
get into it to get the intent of what
you're doing and say oh wait a minute
that doesn't make sense or oh yeah sure
it's doing that sure oh yeah okay I get
it if it's sophisticated we've like
basically like a huge blocks with F and
continues and force and of a block and
then a go to baby it's gonna be much
harder to maintain it might work but the
minute someone tries to change something
it's gonna run into a world of pain use
of common items we hire people from time
to time or we move companies and I mean
the only shared knowledge we really have
is stuff that is already used somewhere
else and that's that's cognitive load
basically the less I have to learn the
better right my previous company had
these interesting items that they didn't
believe in new and delete or a lock and
free everything was cool open and close
and the first fight the first time I saw
the idea of opening and closing an array
I was very confused how do you open in
there a socket I would have understood
if I I would have listened but then the
array
how do you open it how do you close it
so many questions well that's less
questions if you use something common
and usually we think about like iver
design patterns you already know about
but also evoke le vocabulary types or
you don't have to use VHDL if you don't
like to see my other talk but you you
can still have an interface that looks
like it enough so that people are not
confused and of course clean
architecture is usually also a big big
plus for maintainability the minute you
start wanting to to change stuff if you
have circular dependencies or just kind
of messy architectures you will run into
well many problems ease of use of course
like again quality code you want you
wanna you wanna a good you want a good
API design you want an API that is I
think it's got me we said like make it
easy to use and very hard to misuse I'm
not sure Scott Mayer's actually work
from home if you if you can tell me
but yeah make the thing easy to use
and very hard to use the wrong way that
that's that's that's that's I think
something we we we have in some parts of
this TL maybe not so as in in Auvers but
some things are very straightforward you
just you will really have to want to to
mess it up like if you don't try
explicitly to mess it up it would
probably do what you expect
documentation comes with that doesn't
have to be like actual physical
documentation or just like readme or
there is a lot of way of doing
documentation but at least some
documentation at least even a comment
saying this is my precondition this is
my post condition I expect this pointer
to not be no I expect you to give me
only positive integers that kind of
stuff because again if not you create
assumptions and then it's not easy to
use because if you rely on assumptions
you may have problems and generousity
because again you want to reuse it and
the more generic it is the easier it is
to reuse that that's why we usually like
like stuff like templates algorithms and
all that stuff because it's reusable in
other cases okay so far I talked about
stuff that most people in the room you
don't gonna tell me is it that kind of
stuff you want to see are you are we are
we clear on the idea it sounds like
quality stuff that sounds like something
I wanna make a good base yeah people
yeah yeah we should do that that's cool
but then your manager comes it's like
okay cost because I mean you talk about
all that things and the first question
is gonna have it yes but can you do this
for free like it's gonna cost something
right I mean if I had if I had to choose
for bad to good code and both of them
would cost the same thing I would only
have good code so obviously it must cost
something and I mean sure it is like you
might have development time overhead
because I guess it takes more time to
think that to not think and then we run
into the ideas of technical depth
because they actually you you have
something that technical let me so form
of cost is you don't want to pay
something and then it keeps creeping
possibly less than if you actually did
the investment but it's still it's still
the cost that that's lying somewhere
it's the fact that every time you try to
had more stuff for your code base it
just cost you and cost you even if at
the time you was cheap to make and then
of course we tie all that
big ol idea of return on investment it's
like sure you can give me quality but
how do I get my money back as someone
who's actually like paying your salary
or if you own your own company as
someone who's just like funding the
project how am I getting them my money
back whose quality is great but what do
I get out of it is it worth it and you
know that's the quality its quality
worth the cost I'm not gonna say yes or
no because that's not a media yes/no
question and like it there is a gradient
to everything right like the more you
put into quality maybe the less you'll
get maybe not that's that's a question I
think we need to explore before we go on
I have my opinions but let's let's see
what leads so the thing when we entered
the debate of course versus benefits for
quality is that actually it's kind of
bizarre because some parts is actually
is or easy to measure for the cost of
quality if you ask your manager is gonna
be very easy to measure it's like okay
extra developer time that's fine that's
something you can understand it will
pull up an excel sheet and multiply
every Monday by 1 point something 1.2
1.3 2 3 4 times I don't know it's
something you can easily measure its
overhead it's gonna cost me more man
days to get anything done ok that's easy
resource investment same thing I need to
buy servers
I need to buy licenses I need to buy a
hardware right yeah it's easy just I can
put a number on this like I buy X
machines multiplied blah blah blah blah
the icon thing on all that stuff is
fairly straightforward there is still a
figure of like it's not precise science
but you can get a pretty decent ballpark
number benefits on the other hand how do
you put a price on quality like on how
much you gain from it like ok let's say
from now on we focus on portability and
before we didn't how much how much money
do I get like you okay I can't quantify
man-hours and then make a multiplication
by the cost I'm paying my guys and get
an idea of how much I'm gonna pay how do
I know if it's actually worth it because
that's the thing like how do you
evaluate future time not spent because
that's usually that right like you have
quality because in the future your stuff
will not be cost you to to maintain or
even maybe maybe cheaper to maintain you
won't have to spend as much time on bike
fixing or on
debugging stuff but that's that's money
I won't have to spend how do i quantify
money I won't have to spend it's like
selling insurance it's a whole job like
there are people paid reasonable amount
of money to make mathematical model that
tell you how much should an insurance
cost depending on how much you get and
then you start getting into
probabilities I'm not a math person I
have no idea how to compute that I know
if anyone in the room does that's that's
great for you but I don't think I do and
I'm not sure my manager wants to bother
with that either and also potential
damage is everything that's really the
insurance part because like yeah how
much would it cost me if there was a
critical bug in my application and I get
like I don't know a big crash like I
mean the DD de the worst example is like
my like double the people who cut some
coastal or in the fourth and then we use
the call denying the fifth and then it
blew up like how how do you manage the
fact that maybe by skipping some coast
now we might lose a rocket in ten years
how do you even compute that or you get
a data breach or whatever else it's very
hard to compute and I think that's the
biggest problem when you try to hog you
quality with someone is that one of them
is easy to measure the other one it's
very intangible it's just an ideal but
there are actual arguments you can make
that all much more are concise and the
first one is okay who ear let's let's
not let's not spoil you okay here's the
thing
you you you can disagree with me but I
really think that regardless of quality
companies view the code you write as an
investment and when I mean by that is
that if you go to your boss and say okay
we ship the server the service I can
throw away all the code now what is the
first thing is given a graph no are you
crazy
no we spend so much money developing
that of course we're gonna use it like
we're gonna make more features or maybe
we're gonna make a sequel or maybe we're
gonna do something else like I want to
try with you let's try something
how many project did you start or join
try just to think about the number in
your head okay you get an ID how many
project you started by your own or just
join during your career okay fine
how many of those were killed like oh
not in production today in the
but he developing them anymore is that
more than zero
good how many of those have never been
reused in any of a project divert does
anyone has a nonzero value to three
people in the room right as far as you
know yeah you left the company maybe so
yeah and I think that's the biggest ID
like there was a very great talk about
this mmmm suddenly it's in France when
someone was saying basically accounting
views of my of my colors as destroy the
IT model and the argument is was making
is that your software has paid dividends
at the moment you shipped you shipped it
you got a contract you got clients it's
it's paid off you should not look at it
like someone looks as a piece of
furniture bought and said oh no we have
to amortize this in five years
like the accounting thing they teach you
when you start taking accounting classes
every time you buy something there is
something called amortization you say
okay every year I'm gonna evaluate the
value on my on my company assets and at
some point it will be 0 and when it's
zero I can safely throw it away because
it's been properly a multi-season
accounting they never do they kind of do
that in software even if but they not
always decide to go to zero it might you
know go down and down but not really and
I think that's the big problem because
here's the thing code always lives
longer than projected a couple of time I
tried like I was maybe younger I thought
okay I have a very tough decision to
make I can take a shortcut or I might
not take a shortcut but I know one of
them is gonna cost more so I'm gonna ask
my boss how long is this project gonna
last because then I can actually make a
cost versus benefit ratio but what if
remember I got was never the right
result right like if it wasn't as you
said I don't know if it was not equal
say I don't know a free month and they
will never use it again yeah no that's
not gonna happen like unless your
company goes under or something terrible
happens most of your code is gonna live
longer than you projected and then it
brings the question right it's not that
expensive to get quality
I mean it is but not as much as you
might think one of the big reasons
Automation and that's what we're going
to talk about for the rest of this talk
a lot of quality checks and and
guarantees and over stuff like that can
can be attained at a very reasonable
cost and more importantly especially
when we get to the automation parts that
that helps you making your code better
it's done by CPUs is lonely machines and
if there is one thing that emotion is
taught us is that machines are much
cheaper than humans and this is the
further the exact reason why we have
those jobs it's because someone figured
out that it's cheaper to pay someone to
make a program and then run the program
then have people do the thing manually
every time and that's the exact same
thing with code so here is a thing in my
opinion and feel free to disagree with
me in this talk or after the talk and
and tell me I'm wrong but here is a case
I think you can make for quality is that
whether you like it or not whether you
admit it or not you could will be seen
as an investment by your company and if
I have to pick between a bad code in a
good code I think one of them is a
better investment and then how much you
have to put on that investment well with
tooling I think it can be reasonable so
let's see what we can do with that I
call this section by bare-bones
the reason it's called bare-bones is
well because it's the bare bones it's
all the stuff that I think every project
should have but also it might sound dumb
but over the past couple years I maybe
worked on three or four different
projects in different companies none of
them have add all of this at the time
when I joined them and I'm not sure all
of them have all of them sorry I'm not
sure all of those programs have or of
this project have all of those things in
them so we'll play a game ok well I will
check them and we'll see with the room
it does everybody had everything and
then and then you will tell me if it's
if I'm really speaking about stuff that
is so obvious that everybody has it
because I'm pretty sure it's not it's me
of course we're gonna talk some build
but don't worry there's like two slides
so step zero is a reproducible we cut
that word we produce Sybil
you need one I know you don't want to
talk about Bill I know because I talk
about Bill and nobody else wants to but
you need to and here's why the idea is
that you have to developers it scales to
more than two but we have freak entities
in computer science right like one two
and many are no zero one and many so two
is many you have at least two people and
they both pull the same sources same
version some commits some relation
whatever you use same physical copy if
you don't use a CMS I didn't put a cm
let's just assume you use that that I
don't go that bad and then we call Bill
both of them and then they should get
the exact same program or the exact same
error message if one of them gets a
program and the other one gets a
compiler or you have not or you don't
have a reproducible build if two people
gets a program but they differ
significantly differ in the code like in
the binary generated in ways that
basically don't behave the same if they
don't get the same error message but
they both get an error message you don't
have a reproducible bill what I mean up
to some extent probably I mean you may
have time stamps and a bunch of other
stuff in your code but except x times
another finger that like observable
stuff should be the same like your
behavior should be exactly the same you
shouldn't have one that that says one
and the other one that says two when you
put the same input into it unless you're
actually testing a random number
generator but then how do you that's
that's a tricky question yeah so
basically the idea is I built the same
program twice on the same machine or I
built the same program once on two
different machines with the same source
with the same tool chain bla bla bla I
get the exact same result because we
have to talk about automation and how do
you do it to mention if it's not
reproducible what do you do when you get
false positives you start distrusting
the system and if you can't trust it you
can't use it and that's as simple as
that if you have false positives and you
build then hole to mission is out of the
window that's that's why it step zero
and that's the first thing you should
address if you don't have a police
you'll build well every automation you
put there it says green but is it really
I don't know I remember last week it's a
Green and then it actually didn't build
oh it said red and it was actually fine
but on my machine he worked that doesn't
work you don't have to go full very
complex build system you don't even have
to let me talk to you about see Meg
it can just be like build that sh and
GCC star
- Oh like I don't care the important
part is I run this script and I ever get
the same error message or I get the same
program at the end if I don't get that I
don't have a reproducible build and then
I can not automate anything if you have
tests I mean obviously you should have
tests right the build comment should
probably also build the test and run
them and the same way your your build is
is not is reproducible your tests should
be reproducible if I were in the same
time to test twice they should both pass
or both fail for the same tests in the
same reason if I run them on two machine
same story again it's about making sure
you don't have false positives because
then you start distorting the system and
you cannot automate it so yeah if you
want to walk out of this room with one
thing and then just work out everything
else I say maybe remember just this
randomness is the Nemesis of automation
if you have randomness automation will
just fail step one
yeah see what was built I have a
programmer I started zero oh maybe it
was because you need that too good way
anyway automated formatting who here
likes to argue about formatting yeah we
programmers we like to argue way too
many what I think whatever the reason
the response I guess to this question I
push my opponents both way right Iver
Iver you care way too much oh you don't
care at all but in both cases it's gonna
be terrible because I mean I don't know
about you but to me what manual
formatting is a waste of time and the
only thing that is worse is debating
formatting I think I didn't free code
standard initiative so far that I failed
because some people started argues tabs
or spaces versus braces on the next line
like I don't care I don't care as long
as client format can format it just give
me the client format file and I will do
whatever I have to do I will put some
plug in my IDE or I would put a git
commit code and it will just do it there
are several reasons what you want to do
that I guess the biggest one is that
you're gonna have we're gonna have to
start doing some more advanced
automation down the line and that won't
work if you conform at it because humans
can formats but robots when it rules to
format they can't just
we do a Google Doc could standard and
format with it very it's not gonna work
also I think they've so much more
readable if you actually only care about
that because you can just ignore the
whitespace changes I mean you can do
whatever you want
III don't even have an opinion on this I
mean I have several opinions but
whatever works as long as everything you
commit is formatted using the codes the
formatting standard you save and it
could be the standard the default one
from from clang or one of the five or
six times it comes work or it could be
your custom one I don't really care as
long as there's one most ideas have
plugins I think I see most because I
don't know all IDs but yeah all IDs as a
plug-in that unsaved or on-demand can
apply clean format on a whole file and
then you can you how to pre-commit hook
on good on gate if you really want to be
sure that everything that you commit is
formatted it just has to be right so
here's the thing the first time you move
to formatting if you did not have it
before yes you must have heavy file and
some people will argue oh but no it's
gonna break my my history and I will
never be able to do get blame for the
rest of my life well this is not true
anymore and it's been some time now get
as a great comments a argument that says
ignore refs file which is just every
time you make your whitespace change to
your codebase that like you Chen you
apply client format everywhere you just
make it you make only that changes in
the comments only that and nothing else
I mean add that in submitting the new
clang format file and then you note down
that that clang for that that commit ID
and you write it in you push it on the
next commit and get and then you say
every time you do get blame you can
tailgate ignore that commit it's
whitespace I don't care about it because
sure I've done it in the past I've done
claim format everywhere and and and then
some very basic people at QA put every
bug on me because every time we did get
blind that was my line that was changed
that was great I got all the tickets
from from the department that was fun
but there are you just do
that and that it doesn't happen anymore
because it goes through and it doesn't
exert its it's as if it did not see it
you can still you can still not pass the
arguments if really you have a job that
you're to for my reverse mail bug but
99% of the time he wants and you can
just ignore that entirely and the
argument goes out of the window and
every time you change the style you just
had one more one one one thing to the
ref style and it's just as if it never
happened
step two merge requests who here is not
using merge requests it's fine I
understand you when I join my company we
was not using merge request Iver
why why our merge request great yes but
not exactly because I could do code
reviews after the fact yep
I haven't made statistics so I will make
this claim kind of out of my ass but I'm
pretty sure it's right I was like any
review have come and you made after the
commit was merged into whatever
integration branches needs to be as 10%
chance maybe of being acted upon cuz you
know it's merged you can close the JIRA
it's like documentation you will do it
Nader
yeah I used to have a work for there was
ya know will you merge first and then
you like every week or something you're
supposed to look at the history and you
just check the comments and make
comments oh I made tons of comments but
you know the good thing about comments
very ignored when you compile well
that's the exact same thing with this
you can just ignore them so basically
the idea is that no change should be
merged
unless someone as reviewed and approved
it end of the line and how do you do
that you do that with pull requests
because we pull requests you force
contributors to address your concern or
not be able to close vajira or whatever
tracking bug system you use if they
cannot close for task because they have
not addressed your comment well they
will actually address your comment
because that's the only way they get
anything from the door if you say no no
you can address them later
I mean how willing are you to take that
chance
maybe if you trust them you know
wherever live maybe
you can but yeah I wouldn't take it nope
I would lock the integration branch
every geek lab geek blah blah get lab
get up get whatever we all have this you
luck nobody is right nobody can do
anything on that branch even the tech
lead nope nobody even the CEO
nobody can push nobody but we can do
merge requests but only if someone has
actually approved them and then you can
change the code and that's the only way
in because again we're going to do
quality and the only way to a certain
quality is that everything is up to the
standard if there is a shortcut and then
there is a way and you know people take
the path of least resistance because
that's human you have a deadline you
want to go home I've done it I'm not
proud of it but I've done it and I've
said like but it's just me it's fine I
know what I'm doing or it just needed to
go yeah we're super good at making
excuses for ourselves and it's it's
normal that psychology is all at article
about that it's it's we need someone
else to keep us in check basically and
that's the thing and also reviewers are
not limited to humans you can have
robots reviewing you and we're gonna
have some robots reviewing ourselves I
work in sci-fi unless you have adopt and
we're gonna see that but first we need
continuous integration who else who here
as a CI I'm starting to lose hands
interesting should have done this for
every step alright so the idea is that
your reference branch your integration
branch your master you develop you
whatever you call it should always build
and pass the tests that's that's the
basic ID because that's where you are
sitting quality you make sure that
nothing that gets merged is actually bad
and the first step of not being bad is
probably compiling the second step is
passing the tests the first step is
passing reviews we've used we can
certain that with the previous steps
which was merge request now we need to
make sure it actually builds and it
actually passed the tests so how do we
do it it's easy
remember that script we made on step 0
that had to be always right or wrong but
never turn off right but Calif Ron well
that's why we have it because then we
can just
make sure that every time something is
pushed on the master branch on the
whatever branch the bot runs and then it
tells everybody oh stop whatever you're
doing it should not be read and actually
we can take that a step further and say
you know what my robot can run on any
merge request because what's a merge
request is to sum of whatever we have
plus whatever you want to add which is
usually exactly what you will end up
with if you click that merge button
unless you're not using fast-forward and
uh but I mean that's semantics we can
argue about them later but the biggest
idea is like okay now we have a second
review where there's also mandatory
Larry where for a pull request and it's
a robot and until the robot is happy
you're not merging because if the robot
is unhappy well it probably has a good
reason to be unhappy because it's a very
very dumb and very very stupid script
that just says yes or no and you only
says no when you have something critical
like you could not building and that's
very simple
and that way again you can't just go
home and say I passed the test but it's
fine or you don't have like oh who
brought the bill oh it's it's it's John
but he went on vacation sorry
let's fix the build I'm away all my
emails are redirected to the trash can
we're done with the basics who has all
the basics hey I still have some people
cool there's a few issues when you start
doing that so I will try to address them
real quick
the first one is randomness did I talk
about randomness yet okay if you have
randomness you have problems the most
classic one is the bill but sometimes is
red but it's not actually red you know
what happens when you do that you may
you start making it optional because you
might be I have to override them because
you know sometime he says it's failed
but it doesn't know really fail so
you're like ignore the what is wrong
merge and the longer you do that the
longer someone will say you know what
maybe I don't have to wait for the bill
to the bot to build I mean it's gonna
it's gonna have the time it's just gonna
give me technical errors anyway and
people don't like to waste time they
hate wasting time on that automation
even worse than they
and then they like wasting time with no
automation like that automation is even
worse than automation so if you want to
do it and again we're doing quality you
have to make it right so randomness
again it's a problem you may have some I
mean I'm not you you have like you can
have like a I don't know like if one
every thousand billed as a technical
issue because your servers are out of
space I mean it's not great you can try
to have something that is good enough to
be able to recoup from that but I mean
it's not the end of the world if like
half your bill fail for random reasons
or even 10% say then you have a problem
another drive another problem that
people usually break up bring up when I
talking about this is a build up
duration the fact that oh but I have to
wait for the build job to compile and
test all my code before I can merge well
first question I have is like hohohoho
in your area are you for it to get your
code to merge like it does it have to be
like in five minutes
call you wait an hour I mean maybe in
some cases you have a merge request that
cannot wait an hour but most of the time
you will also need I mean all the time
you will need a human review or two and
I hope you don't want to your colleagues
every time you push AmeriCorps saying no
stop whatever you're doing maybe you
might code now I mean I don't know about
you but i just opened the merge request
like a couple of times ago a day like
maybe to free and say oh there's
something i could review night because i
have nothing else to do and then that
review code chances are the board has
done anyway at this point because it's
been an hour
if you about text 12 hours then yes that
might become a problem for your workflow
and then you might have two other issues
maybe you need to speed the project you
probably need to improve your build
process but i mean then again if your
build up takes 12 12 hours how long does
your local bill takes there's a huge set
is gonna be the same issue and means you
can't eat a rate diver so i understand
the arguments but I think it's probably
overused for what it actually is cuz
again I don't think you should rush on a
code review on a merge request unless
everything is on fire but then again the
more quality you have the less chances
something is gonna be on fire anyway and
we can always argue about exceptional
measures for exceptional cases right we
can always make small exception maybe
you take lead in very small condition
could be allowed to touch directly the
master branch blah blah blah but again
exceptions
oh and randomness is also bad okay let's
get something more bit more advanced so
that's everybody in the room get
something so the first thing you're
gonna do is talk about build because
again me because here is the thing all
the tools I showed up to there or very
simple Clank format for example does not
need to be able to pass your code like
he works on the tokenizer it doesn't
actually need to to to to to do the ast
parsing and all that stuff more advanced
tools need to see as much as your
compiler does its need to be able to
read all your code the same way your
compiler with though it needs to have
the right include paths you need to have
the right defines you need to have
everything the same way as if you were
compiling because else is not reasoning
on the same code he has to because of
defines at a bunch of ieave def and a
bunch of other stuff which basically
means every time he wants to analyze a
file with some like advanced tools you
need to get the full compiled command to
compile it there is several way you can
communicate that to a tool the most
common one is the LLVM compiler database
computation database and I think is
probably based to the fact that a lot of
people use clang based tooling which is
great and probably the rest of the
content of this first section the good
news is if you see make its one-line you
had - DC make export compiled commands
to your when you run CMake and you just
generate that file for you and I've yet
to see it fail even with the ugliest
build life C&C Mac and trust me people
send me seemingly sometimes it works
it's just like it should work if you're
running an exotic build system or custom
build system because you brought your
own because it's fun and whatever then
you need to bake that support in that
was a that was a problem in a previous
job of mine where we made their own
build system in one day I say since we
switched that thing I can do any
automation anymore because I can't get
the compilation database that's that's
not cool you need it
so yes if you'd see make it easy if it's
not the best option I thought was bear
which is a magic UNIX command that you
you call on top of your build and they
will try to intercept every siskel to a
fork basically an exec and try to say oh
you're trying to run GCC that miracle
that you're going to compile this file
it's kind of hacky
it's basically recording everything you
do when you wanna make and from that it
tries to infer what is your build
command it's not super it's it kind of
works but it also doesn't work if you
build on Visual Studio and other issues
like that so I mean your best bet is see
Meg or some tool that actually supports
a little vm I think basil has one but I
don't know about the other ones some of
them do because we're gonna do static
analysis next we here uses a static
analyzer okay who is not using clonked
ID of this one think one peep 1% 2% oh
free person what are you using lint lint
oh ok like the original no it's a oh I
don't think I used that one oh I use PCP
check I had so many false positives but
you might edge may vary i I mean I clang
is gonna be used for the rest of this
exploration but if you find one that
works for you just it's fine
it's good I'm not gonna say don't use it
go ahead I just figured out that cpp
check was too slow usually compared to
cranked ID but then again that's that's
my that's my that's my ID so C++ is a
statically typed language I said
formally but I know some SQL people are
going to disagree with me semantically
it's not strong but also compared to C
or JavaScript your mileage may vary but
the idea is that the compiler can result
a lot about the logic of your code right
and that's why the optimizer is so good
it's because it can blaze through a lot
of typing direction and all that stuff
and say yeah ok I see what you mean
but I can also conflict all that tree
into one's a very simple thing well the
same way if you give the same kind of
tool more time and more exploratory
algorithm they can figure out a lot of
stuff and that's basically how static
analyzers work
so it's more than buck checking bank
checking is the first thing they can
tell you but it's not only that for
example if you look at the clanked ID
checks they have a lot of code standard
informants like google says don't use
this use that I think LLVM Mozilla and a
bunch of others have contributed their
own checks to clanked ID and the OID is
the same is like our company has a good
standard that says you should use those
patterns and not dues patterns you can
have a tool that tells people all you're
breaking the code standard there and fix
it
are you not gonna merge you can suggest
better better items are we going to talk
about modernizing in the next section
but that's to be classic like maybe you
should use o2 there or have you heard
about this Finkle right or wrench for a
bunch of other stuff like that there is
also a few checks that can actually find
suboptimal bits of codes the classic one
is usually a missed opportunity for muth
like the places where you should just
have to move but you did not and then
you're gonna hang your copy where you
could just not do it the compile again a
lot of those things look like what you
could get with W all the warnings of
earth but I think to some extent
compiler developers restrain himself or
from anyone in spirits especially if it
requires deep analysis of the call stack
or off because I mean people complain a
lot about compilation time already so
better put this check in a 9:00 dinner
in a dedicated tool but that you can use
afterwards so yeah I mean again clanked
ID is my recommendation if you find
another one great for you [ __ ] ideas
like a hundred configurable checks at
least and also the big thing it has it
can suggest patches it can say yeah
you know what your code is not great
here but here is what you could do here
is a patch just just put it to passion
then you're done and also six is flying
it's super modular and you can extend it
and as we will see next
it's interesting you can do a lot of
stuff of that how do you got how do you
get from from no static analysis to
static analysis because that that's one
of the thing I hear sometimes like oh
yeah that sounds super cool but my code
base is probably a billion valuation of
all dues how do I do it and I would say
it's the exact same way you had warnings
to your compiler that you did not use
before you check out a branch you add
the warning or you had the check
on your static analyzer you run it you
fix all the errors when all the others
are fixed yay good merge and then every
new code will run move that flag and
then we'll check for it and it won't get
merged unless it's fixes and you just
repeat the process until you have enough
and since the idea is that quality can
be iterative you will probably never
have enough you will always find all
there is this new check that we could
introduce next
just my recommendation is doing step by
step don't try to put like client ID -
everything because yeah you're gonna
have like so many errors you tell me on
my crash or something like no don't do
that but pick a select ones fix go again
like you don't go from no warning - mine
too - wall - W error in one go like that
that's just insane you go you go step by
step and again like I said and that's
the next section you don't always have
to do it yourself again we want to
automate and that's that's what the big
part comes in and that's where the
automation part of automation comes
because like automate automation of
compliation like pull request that's
that's arguably some form of automation
but here is the image to me the big
game-changer is that a lot of
refactoring is actually quite systematic
I mean it's supposed to be systematic
that's the point right you replace by
top pattern a by per ton B so you might
start with like control H like social
replace in some in simple cases it works
and then you start getting creative say
you know what I think with a reg X I
could match everything
maybe usually you stop being unable to
beat the Reg X before it actually does
everything you want at least that's my
that's my that's my usage like I can
write the Reg X but I basically
debugging the Reg X as I write it and
once it's executed there is no way I can
really together so and the big thing we
can do instead is ast matching for I
have not explained it before but est is
abstract syntax tree it's still tree
representation of your program basically
as seen by the compiler and and and the
big idea is that with that we can we can
start doing queries on your code and
then basically replacements for example
one of the things you could do is say
okay I want to find all the funk
in my code that take an argument that
this passed by construct that we got
from their five signature and then stole
them in an internal class variable like
you take like a string by contract and
you copy it basic let make a copy and
Cincy plus plus eleven we know that it's
suboptimal you should take them my ref
ref and you should start move them the
reason is if you get called by a
temporary you say one more you save one
copy if you get called by something that
was about to be destroyed someone can
just pass it to you and again you save
the copy and I mean it's it's for string
it's for vectors for anything that is
kind of a heavy to move that would be
very painful to do manually I don't even
know I would do that with reg exes
I mean it might be possible if you have
like a very very good naming pattern
that can detect like stuff but no the
solution is like oh hey clang don't you
have something that says yeah you should
modernize you couldn't pass by a value
when you can and then you just do that
and then Clank will just emit patches
that you just have to to put in your
code base and then and then you don't
there's a lot of them and modernize I've
used them several times historically a
lot of migration from after I
annihilated from a 0-3 to 11 but also
when I was wanting to migrate from 11 to
4 to 14 or 17 for example you can
replace all the news by make UNIX
because naked new is bad but sadly C++
11 missed miss make unique for some
reason it was missed and it only ended
up in 14 so the day you had up 14 you
can just say yeah you know what
remove all those a new expression ugly
thing that you do you can just make make
unique everywhere it's just cleaner you
can force o to and arrange for
everywhere that it makes sense when you
start waiting to 14 and 17 you want to
get rid of the auto pointer you may have
a new code base the good thing is that
there is a check for that you might get
you won't get away with a control edge
because you have to actually explicitly
stored movement now and clang can do
that for you you can remove a lot of
code by it say yeah you know what you
can just do a default value equal
default equal delete instead of whatever
tricks we used in all free and that's
another big one and I think that's I
mean that's not all of them
that's just like four or five
the one I used there's like ten of them
or something now maybe more of a keep
hiding anymore more and more in a as
time passes so yeah basically the idea
is that you can do a lot of things you
can remove duplicated stuff to help you
like migrate code you can adopt new
patterns by replacing old constructs and
old old items by something more more
recent and more modern you can some
cases find suboptimal code is probably
the least one the least I used it for
but it's possible there's a bunch of
performance check in client ID that kind
of do the trick but the biggest thing is
this systematic it's all across the card
base well I mean I oh yeah it is all
across the code base you just feed all
the CPP file you have and it will just
do it for all of them you won't miss
anything if you want an example actually
the thing is it's only the starting
point because okay sure you can I have
done it I have applied it to magnet code
basis but then i I ate another problem
it says sometimes there are patterns in
my code that are not really like common
items but I know the bad I know I want
to migrate them but I don't know how
like ctrl H will not work for example
what do I do and the thing is since it's
based on clang you can write your own
you write a piece of C++ that basically
act as a as a match sure you match you
match three expressions basically and we
and then you can say okay for all the
expression you matched I mean this code
is replacement and then it just
generates a patch that you can apply if
you want an example one I know previous
company of mine who remembers F writable
strings anyone ever used that okay back
in the days a long time ago
C compilers would put like literal
string literals in the data in the data
segments you could you could modify them
quickly enough someone realized it was a
very bad idea so no no it should be in
the text segment because obviously those
things are constant right you should not
be able to modify a string literal
because it's not supposed to be changed
but we already had code at the time
and instead of fixing it because that
means introducing some combs left and
right we just said no no we just used a
chef writable string somewhere I know it
was in the 90s I guess and that that
that helped for some time until you say
we're dropping airfryer table strings
you can't have it you want to upgrade
your compiler you need to get rid of it
and then you look at your code is like
oh this been 15 years since we just
continued adding more and more of that
and the funny thing about concerts is
viral right like it's not enough to just
forever figure out every place is when
someone takes a string literal make
constant fun because it passes to other
api's which also did not care about cost
and took everything by a
non-concessional transporter so what do
we do well we take an expert from the
company and we said you fix this because
we need to upgrade it does that for
about couple months and then he goes to
his manager and it's like you put me on
another project on my oh I'm out I'm out
I think we burned three programmers like
that the fourth one says no way I'm not
gonna burn like those three I'm gonna
make up I'm gonna study this thing and
I'm gonna make a bot that's just gonna
do it for me because of Li like
basically it starts at level zero it has
constant River and then it fixes the the
irregularity all the way down the api's
and that's the only way we could switch
from I don't know if you see free I
think that's the only way we could
upgrade from GCC free to GCC four or
five at the time and that was talking
about that was blocking us from moving
to C++ 11 way into the 2010 because we
were using a feature from an old GCC and
there was no way we could get it anymore
I don't think we ever tried paying them
for getting it hopefully we didn't
anyway we managed to do it and the
reason we managed to do it at the time
was because of that without it I don't I
don't know if we could have made I think
we would have just stayed in C++ or free
say yeah okay I guess the white double
strings oh we would have burned more
programmers and not sure we would even
have achieved it so yeah big ideas you
could becomes a database like you could
is data right yeah we usually say code
is code and data is date I've learned to
segments that's obvious but your code is
actually a database because you can
parse it you can read it as a tree
and it's a tree and everything stops and
everything like that and once it gets a
tree well it becomes a database and once
it's a database what's the thing you can
do in the database well you can query of
course but you can insert you can update
you can delete and and that just opens
up another paradigm it's like you could
these data and since it's data you can
basically run migration steps the same
way you update your sequel database
saying find everything that looks like
this and replace it like that or just
simply tell me how many rows match this
expression this is things I should
probably fix and again at a large scale
I heard something like Google invested
so much into this that we have more BOTS
than humans making comments on the
codebase at this point for basically run
by robots robots are cool I made a safer
game so yeah I think we user-defined
refactoring is being the next step and
this is where you are you go from like
cool tooling to really oh okay we we can
actually take a significant part of our
tag depth and just chug it away by
having automatic process just taking
care of it for us like I would say it's
kind of a shortcut to pay back your tag
depth I'm not saying it's a good way it
says it I mean some people might argue
that it's an argument for tag depth so
yeah you know what you have boss to fix
it now I'm not sure it's actually good
one but whatever in any case you can
also introduce breaking changes because
one of the problems I also saw in a lot
of code base is that nobody forty could
actually fix like change an API entirely
and that's one of the big reason for
example in C++ we refuse to deprecated
stuff until we unless it takes a long
time to change because there is always
going to be people raising their hand
and say oh I have 15,000 uses of a
two-pointer in my code you can't
duplicate it I need that and then you
can say here here's a script run it on
your code base and now you don't have an
argument anymore and now we can actually
move forward and and now you don't have
to have like an API we free overloads
and have the arguments or unused but
you're still keeping them because
because you don't want to change the
code base
kind of stuff you can fix your project
and even better if you publish library
and you're afraid your client will not
accept a breaking change you can say hey
here's a here's a client ID check I made
just run it on your codebase and you
automatically upgrade the same way you
say hey run this on your DB you will add
the later schema it's exactly the same
thing here is a migration script that
goes with my breaking change so you can
actually continue working and like I
said cleaning old code becomes much
cheaper again not an argument for having
tied that guy on time but this is the
last pot so it's perfect so right if you
have to remember like three or four
things the first one is that quality is
worth the cost because the cost sorry
because whatever you think your code is
gonna be seen as an investment so invest
in the good investment you can use to
lean to save water quality which is the
first step making sure that nothing gets
worse and the second step which is more
about automation is raising the quality
level and also raising it by using
automation not just manually spending
like three weeks of tag depth just like
removing go-to pointers by hand because
that's that first of all you're never
gonna get at the budget and - yeah yeah
like I said you burn programmers doing
that because we hate doing stuff that
can be repeated it opens new horizon
it's not just like you can do stuff easy
so you can just do stuff that were
basically impossible before I I am Not
sure we have similar the idea I think we
think the beginning of the paradigm I
know some companies are more advanced
than others but I think we only we
haven't seen everything that people can
think about the simple idea that now you
can mainly possibly distribute an update
of your library ver script that says hey
run this on your database and on your
code and then you can adopt the new
version and yeah I could make a breaking
change cuz it's fine I didn't break your
usage he was effects oh and did I
mention random s I mean if you're gonna
have to trust robots to change your code
you're gonna have to trust them that
they're not lying to you when they
actually run and say yeah see the tests
are still passing and you didn't break
anything
if you want to know more I had only
space for two because they have very
long titles I was told by a colleague
that is actually a tactic to be sure
that if you that you do it if they have
over for the name for themselves the
first one is an example from an old
co-worker of mine Fred who runs the the
Paris user group now I think he did that
for a GUI library at my previous company
but I'm not entirely sure anyway it's a
pretty it's a good introduction on what
you can do with it with example of how
you or how to write your own checks it's
a very hot topic every major conferences
at least one talk about what I did we've
lived tooling cpp con has won every year
cpp now as when every year there's a
bunch of them and then if you want more
to talk about the theory the first part
of quality software capitalism that
stuff like a lot of the ideas I took
about quality come from the ideas of
social capital that was coined by
David's ankle 2006 pretty good talk some
people I said it should have been a
keynote I can of agree it's a long
discussion about why you want quality
and I mean it's made by the finance
company so I guess we know we know a
thing or two about investment o and
forevermore I think your build should be
destroyed thank you any questions yes
I've had by pitching them the idea
shanell code the producers at Howard is
more like a liability yes yes it's ya
know it's it's it's a big thing like I
said like the talker was mentioning
sadly in French I don't know if there is
an is there is an equivalence in a in a
in a more worldwide language but the
idea is that the microservice quote for
example excuse me he's doing a lot of
that they're like micro services or as
the name implies Micro Oh God very small
in scope and the idea is that
you make a v1 and then you want to make
a v2 one day you just go to the insurer
and say you know what just open the code
and if it looks terrible just throw it
away and write it I don't care it's been
in production I paid for its cost it's
fine
I don't have to look at it as a as an
investment but yeah one of the argument
I made for qualities especially in C++ I
think in over industries like that that
relies a lot on those code bases because
we tend to be long like JavaScript is as
I think in a time frame much shorter
time elapsed and then C or C++ code base
have been around forever and I don't
think most of them are going anywhere
whatever your manager says and so yeah I
think that's one a big argument I agree
maybe we should look at more the code
and say yep it paid off we shipped we
got money we got contracts now we can
throw it away
but I know most of them will never hear
that argument and I mean if you can have
it then I mean that's not a way of
gaining quality right if you rewrite it
you can rewrite it better the next time
I mean that's that's what we learn I
guess
but or you can just make it at this more
modern and use mobile and practices
which is also something you want to do
but in a lot of cases you can't you have
to you have to reuse it you will reuse
it and then the argument for quality is
even bigger is like it's gonna cost us a
lot like I said the writable strings
that broke like three programmers unless
remain one of them quits like I mean
that's the kind of stuff and you have a
question more for more for documenting a
question by the way you have to have
what yes I mean several reasons but oh
yeah I had I had a mandatory job it had
to be green like I think you eat
front-end tests every night they had to
be green for you to be accepted as a
merge at least a third of them failed
half the time for technical reasons and
the QA did not understand the problem
they just bugged booked to JIRA so I
spent half my mornings on Mondays I
think I spent most of my money's at the
end
just staying up it's just technical
please we push manually and then check
them one by one set up the read push is
great you can actually accept my changes
like that gets to teaches people the
first argument people put is like can we
just remove those and yeah you can't put
also then you have no more tests get a
question yes yes yes so yeah I've had
this debate before and people saying
okay if you use fast-forward only the
problem is you need to rerun the test
every time you'll be base and if you
project as more than three people
working on it
you'll always be basing and rerunning
the tests yes I've seen some solutions
by using more robots basically people
have said okay as as as as soon as it's
been reviewed and like basically you may
you may you run like a test at the
version someone made it like you render
you're under the standard pipeline and
you run the manual review and then the
guys fix merge it doesn't actually merge
it goes in a queue somewhere and the
queue the only thing it does is take the
next commit rebase apply green merge
else skips and back and boom boom boom
boom boom
basically the robot becomes a scheduler
and you just take this the commit one by
one that's one way if you want
fast-forward only and to be sure that
you will at this point you don't even
have to run your my job on on your
master branch because the master head is
always the last comma to validate it
just because you be before you did fast
format so that's one option on the other
way if you willing to accept that
sometime your master will actually get
read because of the fact that the the
actual merge created a conflict that you
could not see in in the pool request
that could be a way but then you have to
institute like
that is okay if master is red I do not
merge anything except something that
makes it doing and that one will have to
be fast forward that's an option again I
mean if you you can have done both now
and I haven't done the full but yet I
wish I had I know some companies do I I
like it I think it's more guaranteed to
have like honest quality you're 100%
sure you integration but which always be
going because the robots will literally
never merge it unless fast forward
passes all the tests but it requires a
bit more infrastructure I don't know if
some like paid for solutions actually
have a way to say like rebates and merge
until it's fine like we have a queue
system there should probably I mean
there's a way someone has automated that
obviously but I don't know of any
solution on top of my head I know some
companies I think Google has that for
example but they have everything custom
so I don't know if it's a product you
can buy probably not but I wouldn't be
surprised that would be something I
would sell in an enterprise edition for
example if you want to make like I mean
if I was selling and I'm just throwing
this over so I can't actually tell you
but that that would be my guess if not
just yep very you can just say okay
let's go with merge but then the first
thing happen if anything is red the only
thing except it is a fast-forward merge
that that fixes the build anything else
nope not gonna happen and then you you
check with your team how often does it
happen if it happens every free every
every month then sure fine
if it happens much more regularly then
maybe you should look into the other
yeah cuz they have a large-scale and I
don't know how we solved it but yeah the
bill bots yeah I think I think that's
the best thing like you flagged emerge
for a robot to actually pick it and
rebase it
well if anyone is watching there's a
business opportunity there I think
because I would pay for that stuff yes
yes I guess it varies from company for
company and how fast is your up
personally I would say if it's done
doing the day I don't mind but I mean
depends on how big all the features you
do right like if most of the future I
work on take me several hours to work on
anyway I can wait another couple hours
for that to me burns I'm not gonna die
from it and then also depends like do
you need need to get it in the nightly
build if you have like 90 tests or if
you like deploying like frequency of
deployment is the big question I call
fast you deploy my video game we we
pushed the beta version to beat a tester
every night for example so if you have
something very important like for
example usually don't open a merge
request on Friday night if you want
people to play over with the weekend
that's that's usually the big the big
the big bottleneck is oh I really want
feedback on this on this feature I made
and the biggest feedback we get is
obviously people playing on the weekends
or beta testers because we're just like
random people who play again for free in
the weekend give us bug reports yes you
really wanted in the you want you wanted
in the in the build that it's gonna be
made on Friday night because nobody's
gonna merge it on Saturday I mean unless
you have company that works on Saturday
but that's not a question yes
it's very easy well basically the
example I was I was I was I was giving
his yeah people were using see before
counts existed so every every every
stray every little was a char star and
then when he started became conscious
start just use F writable switch to not
have to change all the strings in the
code and then we had a API so we built
around the fact that all strings were
basically chars and like I said we
burned three programmers until the
fourth one say I'm writing something in
clang automatic he may have had to fix
some manually but I think most of it was
just writing a client ID thing that just
spread the consonants like virally up
until there was either a conflict of API
that he really needed to solve like
someone's actually relying on it which
you shouldn't have like someone was
actually modifying it which would have
been a bug anyway most of the time he
was just making all the api's that's
that start from string literals virally
Const until he was done there's test and
and we've definitely managed to get rid
of it and we could actually drop the F
writable strings and move to C++ 11 that
was I don't know like four years ago you
made a talk about it but it's again in
French I don't know if there is an
English version maybe at C PPP I am not
entirely sure I could check
[Applause]
yeah no actually with a complex enough
match sure you could probably check if
there is a non-contact s or not of a
variable in a function or if there is an
immutable attea plot and then I ought to
suggest it Const that that I mean that
seems plausible right you just have to
integrate over everything under a
function note and say do you do a right
a right axis on this on member variables
yes or no or do you call a girl comes
matter if there is none then it could be
constant but I wouldn't be surprised if
tools at that that doesn't sound like
something impossible to do question tool
for what I mean no really I mean the
tool itself is just the fact that your
pipeline runs and his concern is is like
working so what I mean the problem is of
course like randomness in tests is one
of them and the other one is gonna be
I've had I have a lot of infrastructure
issues in the past like under scaled or
whatever like half the Harris was like
oh docker try to boot and he could not
reserve an image big enough and then he
couldn't compile or no space left on
device is my favorite I really really is
it really is my strong opinion that no
programmers should spend his time fixing
like we Jenkins please rebuild because I
ran out of space just like space is free
at this point almost like you can go on
Amazon and buy like a bezel innovate for
nothing it's insane the amount of man
hours we spend of Engineering's fixing
stuff that could just be solved by
buying more hardware like and that's
that's the big thing Google realized
like an engineer could be in Europe in
America it doesn't doesn't matter it
costs a lot to make them do anything on
the other hand aldo is cheap and i can
hire more hardware by the time I finish
reading a slide
having more high engineers fixing those
kinds of problem is not scalable it
takes forever to hire them and also most
of the time if you don't want to do that
job because it's boring and very
palliative and we hate that so ya know
just like yeah it's it's that good ol ID
that you need to spend money to make
money like yes you want to save money on
all this thing we'll spend you wanna
save money well spend more money you
savings you know time by spending money
on hardware like that that's a thing
thank you
[Applause]